Our next guest is
(Ross laughing)
an actor and seasoned TV and radio host
who was the heart of BET's "106 & Park"
and now he's part of an incredible new health
and nutrition initiative, here to tell us more.
I'm really excited to talk to him about that.
I love him.
Cause I so believe in what he's doing.
It's Terrence J!
Hi, Terrence!
(audience applauding and cheering)
What's up, guys?
Coordinating with us!
Ross, what's up? Drew, what's up?
It is so good to see you.
What's up, Terrence?
How are you?
Drew, I'm amazing.
I'm so excited to be on this show.
I love you guys.
Ross, I haven't seen you in a while, buddy.
How are you?
I am great.
You know,
we worked together on E!
I know.
I know! And I'm so happy to see you.
How come you don't age? You look better than ever.
It's a lot of eating healthy,
which we'll talk about in a minute.
Well, you are a part of a big push
to get healthy food habits into the lives
of students at historically Black colleges and universities.
Tell us everything.
Thank you so much.
You know, I moved to California about 10 years ago
and I had no idea
some of the healthy eating options that existed.
I grew up in North Carolina.
I grew up, you know, eating pork
and a lot of fried chicken and meat.
And when I came out here,
I slowly but surely got introduced
into healthy living and healthy lifestyle.
And it's done wonders on my skin,
it's done wonders on my energy level,
it's done wonders on my productivity.
And now there are so many vegan options
that taste just like the real thing
that I wanted to create a program
that can help inspire people
when they're making those decisions.
So I partnered with Aladdin
and we've been visiting HBCU campuses and,
and I've come up with this menu for students
that can hopefully get them started on the right track
of eating healthy and eating the right way.
Terrence, I love that you're doing this.
What, what is it that makes you want to do it?
What, what drives you?
Just growing up and never having those options.
And now, you know, in my thirties,
now being introduced to it and saying,
"Oh wow, it doesn't have to be, you know,
a dry celery stick and a carrot and-
and of those little tomatoes,"
it can be incredible tasting food
and it's going to help you live longer
and help you have more energy.
And once I kind of mastered that
it was all on how I can spread it.
And, you know, students at historically black colleges,
getting this implemented in that diet,
I think is going to be a great step.
You're partnering with Aladdin Dining Services, right?
They provide food to a number of HBCUs across the country.
So how do they work on this mission with you?
I didn't want to do any partnerships
where the food didn't taste right
because I don't want people to be introduced to it,
and they're like,
"Aw, man, I never even want to try,
you know, any vegan options again.
Cause it was, it wasn't good."
And so we curated a very fine-tooth menu
with things like nachos.
There's a healthy hamburger option on there
with carrots made for the bacon.
We came up with an incredible dessert
that tastes just like the real thing.
And so, you know, we came up with an incredible menu
that I really think students are gonna love.
I just thank you so much for everything that you're doing.
We have been so excited to talk about this with you.
(upbeat ending theme music)